hey guys today it is the first of a
December my name is Jess and you are
watching gamespot nice blood-borne
servers have been taken down for
emergency maintenance sony japan
announced that while the playstation 4
game remains playable offline the online
modes will be unavailable for a few days
the publisher of says that they will
update players again when the
maintenance ends while sony japan didn't
specify what the maintenance is
addressing kotaku has reported that it
may have something to do with an exploit
that lets players unlock the recently
released old hunters dlc content and
free lead hosting engineer Tim warneke
explained on reddit that the publisher
identified and exploit and serious
issues that exist in the game any report
from tech news night digitimes has
suggested that 12 million units of
nintendo's new NX console will be
shipping to retailers next year citing a
Taiwanese source said to be familiar
with nintendo's NX production plans they
reported that Nintendo's initial
production target was 20 million units
but complications resulted in a scaling
back of that number Nintendo is yet to
reveal details of the Nintendo annex and
has said they don't plan to discuss it
publicly until 2016 a recent wall street
journal article reported that the system
was a console mobile hybrid with what
they called industry-leading technology
DigiTimes has a history of consulting
with accurate sources related to
Nintendo's internal ongoings so there
might be some truth to this latest
report finally the publisher for dead or
alive xtreme 3 has released an official
statement regarding recent comments made
about the game not coming to Western
markets to get you all caught up aka
tecmo representative made a facebook
post suggesting that the voyeuristic
volleyball game would not come to the
west due to concerns about audience
reaction to the game's depiction of
women that said the comments were vague
and in precise so they could be
interpreted in a nun
ways koei tecmo has now released an
official statement that claims those
comments only reflected that individuals
opinion and not that of the company
adding we remain focused on delivering
the best in fighting entertainment's to
our fans around the world while
consciously respecting and strategizing
to support the different global
audiences the dead or alive franchise
lends itself to let me know down in that
comment section what your take is on the
Dead or Alive Xtreme 3 situation and
head to gamespot we've got news on Star
Wars ice cream and graphics issues with
Just Cause 3 on PC that is it for me
today as always to let me know what you
cared about and I will catch you again
tomorrow